you know in the markets they call it the
constantis uh the issue being
um is there going to be stimulus and
that's one of the things that
people are seizing on amid reports right
now uh
that chuck schumer and mitch mcconnell
have at least discussed the possibility
of getting something out even in the
lame deck
of the lame duck session i should say a
good opportunity to bring this up with
senator ben
cardin uh the democratic senator from
the beautiful state of maryland happy
thanksgiving to you senator thanks for
taking the time
neil it's good to be with you and happy
thanksgiving to you
thank you very much um on this stimulus
i know it seems like the great
long t's as they call it in the markets
but hopes were raised a little bit
you know last week senator on talk that
and that's all it was talk that that
something could be cobbled together in a
lame duck session how likely would that
be you think
neil it's desperate right now small
businesses will not survive until next
year
if we don't get some additional help the
unemployment benefits will end
some at the end of this year some have
already ended
families are desperate with the
unemployment rates still very high
state and local governments are laying
off workers can't provide essential
services we're in the midst of this
pandemic
it's escalating congress needs the act
and here's the good news
there's been lots of conversations among
democrats and republicans
on let's come together let's compromise
let's have a bipartisan bill
but let's make sure it is significant
enough to get us through to the spring
of next year
that's where i hope we can find a common
uh grounds
to move legislation and i can tell you
it is our highest priority
is to get a covet package done during
this lame duck session
you know while i have you senator one of
your colleagues uh bernie sanders i
think you know him
um it's all about advertising for the
job
uh of of labor secretary
uh no indications yet whether joe biden
would be interested in him for that
position if any position but what do you
think of that
well you know we have a deep bench of
people who are qualified to serve in the
biden cabinet i can tell you i have the
utmost confidence that joe biden's
cabinet will reflect this nation will
reflect the priorities that he has been
he campaigned on uh during the
presidential campaign
so i'm not going to get ahead of the
president-elect i'll let him make his
judgments
to make sure he has a balanced cabinet
but i have confidence
that he will consider all qualified
nominees
that's a very diplomatic answer senator
um i expect no less
so let me ask you about this then uh
that the progressives in your party the
the
the what you might call the ones who
they
argue got joe biden elected that's their
argument
that they owe him um or that he owes
them do you think he
owes this this part of your party
uh seats in a cabinet and even more
i i think what joe biden needs in his
cabinet is to carry out his commitment
to represent all of america that he's
going to
make sure that his supporters and those
who did not vote for him are represented
by the policies of abiding
administration so i think he needs to
govern
for this nation and yes in doing that i
think he will appeal to the broad
categories of support that he got during
this campaign you know 80 million votes
almost that's a
that's a broad sector of america uh it's
hard to pinpoint
exactly uh one particular group that he
needs to make sure or represented here
or there
he's got to represent this country
so one of the ideas that the
president-elect has bandied about
senator
uh his student loan debt forgiveness i
believe he pegged it at around
ten thousand dollars others and some of
those progressives i referred to so are
saying it should be fifty thousand
dollars others say
so all student debt where are you on
this how likely is this as an immediate
uh course of action on the part of the
president-elect
neal before covet 19 this was a
very important issue we had to deal with
that's the second largest amount of debt
held by americans next to credit cards
uh it's entirely too expensive to be
able to attend college today as a result
families have large amounts of student
debt we need to provide relief before
covet 19. now with covet 19
there's so many defaults that are out
there we have to figure out a way
to ease the burden on american families
so yes we have to deal with the
realities of the amount of debt that's
outstanding now
but also have a program moving forward
to make college education more
affordable you should be able
to send your child to college without
going into debt
and we need a program that accomplishes
that so i hope
we'll have a dual program here one to
deal with the outstanding debt
but also one to deal with the cost of
college moving forward and yes i think
this is an urgent issue
and should be part of the early part of
the biden administration
all right we'll see what happens senator
ben gardner had a safe thanksgiving in
the meantime
i'll be well very nice you to come in on
saturday we appreciate that